-We spoke backstage. I'm very,
very happy with this look.
-You know what? Are you?
Because I feel like
I should be strapping
Sean Connery to a table
and firing a laser at his balls.
[ Laughter ]
-It is. It has a very nice,
like, classic Bond villain.
-Yeah, it's like a --
-Like a gentleman --
Like, you're like
a gentleman villain.
-Yeah, I'm like a jerk
from the '60s who smokes a pipe.
[ Laughter ]
You know?
That's what I was going for.
-Yeah, well,
mission accomplished.
[ Laughter ]
You --
I mean, let's be honest.
You are -- I know you to be
a lovely person.
-Thank you.
-You're very --
"A.P. Bio"
is another example of it.
You're very good at --
at playing jerks.
-Yeah. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
What is that?
I don't know.
You're probably asking me
what that is --
I want you to tell me,
because I don't know.
Like, if you're my ---
-Maybe, your whole life,
you've been such a good person
and you're so kind to everyone,
and yet you have this tickle
in the back of your head,
and you're like,
"I wish there was somewhere..."
-You know what?
-Yeah.
-I think you're actually
totally right.
I think I've spent, like,
the majority --
and this is actually true.
And you might not think this
from the characters I play.
I do consciously try to be
a really, really good person.
So I find people
like the characters I play
so despicable and disgusting
that I have to satirize them.
[ Laughter ]
I have to -- I have --
I'm like, "I have to get inside
your head and figure out, like,
'How can you possibly behave
this way?'"
And I have to make it funny --
otherwise, I'll go crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-You -- You --
For those who don't know,
you are a Harvard professor
who's fallen from grace
who is now teaching,
in Toledo, A.P. Bio.
-Yep, mm-hmm.
-One of the things
that's been great about the show
is the kids, the classroom --
they're incredible actors.
-They are.
-And the longer
the show's been on,
the more you get to know them.
And you also
get to work with friends,
as far as like Patton Oswalt
and Paula Pell.
That just must make work
so much fun.
-It's kind of a dream job.
-Yeah.
-Not gonna lie.
It's amazing to be on a show
with such smart, funny,
incredibly talented people.
And being onscreen
with those people is fun --
being offscreen
is maybe even more fun...
-Sure.
-...when you're sitting around
and you kind of say and do
anything.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah?
-That's where, like,
you know,
the gloves really come off.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
-Yeah.
It's -- Yeah, it's pretty great.